de pouvoir inviter ginette mais bienvenu
alors ses sept enfants tu es un fan de
simon tahar oui j'aime bien aussi moins
d'heure puis plein d'autres bon alors ce
midem 85 pascal légitimus bienvenus
comment la raison pour laquelle passe
pourquoi comment et la loupe pourquoi
parce que nous avons sorti un disque qui
est sortie du téléphone sonne toujours
deux fois donc un film we et le titre du
disque c'est une box just box et ses
musiques comme gabriel yared d'accord on
peut être donné en très rapidement un
petit couple est peut-être parce qu'il
paraît que les murs sont très étranges
son étrange aurait par exemple c'est du
si du français qui ont arrangé à la
sauce américaine ça donne par exemple le
gard at-on pis ça donne un carton jaune
tarifs tu va germer tes tripes ça donne
du gore ndjobi aux tripes
et puis il ya des mots comme ça un peu
toi particulier comme pas être choqué
pète goss zeiss vario qui pète alors bon
c'est ça veut dire que ça veut dire son
sourire quand même un petit peu la
pochette et puis quand on écoute a fait
américain mais c'est complètement
français d'accord donc les pascal
légitimus et bourreau de miles à
septmoncel et bernard campan et d'un
enfant donc ça c'est encore la troupe
qui a encore frappé le téléphone sonne
toujours deux fois sur tous les bons
écrans oui c'est surtout au cadran et
puis je sais que tu joue le rôle d'un
animateur de radio alors l'animateur de
radio par exemple annoncerait bernard
lavilliers le bal de balle est
maintenant mes soeurs et frères bernard
lavigne est désormais super ça va
swinguer c'est génial